هذا الهجوم المكثف والذي وصف هنا بانه
الاكثر تعقيدا الذي استهدف العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كييف منذ بدايه الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا نتحدث عن استهداف العاصمه
الاوكرانيه
بثمانيه عشر صاروخا من بينها سته صواريخ
من طراز كنجال وتسعه صواريخ من طراز
كاليبر التي تطلق من البحر الاسود
وصاروخ من طراز اس 4 وصاروخ من طراز
اسكندر هذه الهجمه الصاروخيه المكثفه التي
وجهت نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه ادت الى تضرر
عدد من المناطق عدد من المباني في احياء
مختلفه من العاصمه الاوكرانيه نحن الان في
حي اخر ايضا لنطلع على بعض الاضرار
الجانبيه لهذا القصف ولهذه الضربات التي
تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها استطاعت ان
تتصدى لهذه الص
مجملها ان صحت هذه الروايه هذا يعني ان
الدفاعات الجويه بما فيها من منظومات
دفاعيه غربيه وجهت وتسلمتها اوكرانيا تشمل
ايضا وحده دفاع جوي من طراز باتريوت
الامريكيه هي التي تمكنت من اسقاط هذه
الصواريخ ومنع
ما كان لا يحمد عقباه في حال حدث بالفعل
وفي ذات الوقت كان هناك تصريح لوزير
الخارجيه واختم بذلك يقول ان هناك حراك
دبلوماسي كثيف لتعزيز الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ولاغلاق الاجواء وهو يشير بذلك
ايضا الى احتمال ان يتم تسليم طائرات
لاوكرانيا